Çeviri: Orkun Nazim Kadioglu
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Merhaba herkese.
Evet, Batuhan'ın söylediği gibi
benim adım Banu.
Banu ne demek biliyor musunuz
bilmiyorum ama
Banu farsça bir kelime ve
kadın demek.
Evet, kraliçe, hanımefendi,
tüm kadın kavramlarını
kapsayan bir kelime.
Ve ben kadın hastalıkları ve
doğum uzmanıyım.
Şimdi...
Ayrıca, Afrika'dan New York'a,
Van Başkale'den İran sınırından
Nişantaşı'na kadar
binlerce kadının doğumunu yaptırttım,
ameliyat ettim
ve belki yüz binlercesini
muayene ettim.
Dolayısıyla, böyle kadın deyince birazcık
konuşma hakkım var herhalde.
O yüzden sizlerle "kadın"ı
konuşmak istiyorum.
Klasiktir, neyle başlayalım?
Türk Dil Kurumu ile başlayalım.
Evet. Kadın! Erişkin dişi insan.
Mutabık mıyız? Evet.
Peki.
Erişkin ne demek?
Ona gelelim.
Bu, Dünya Sağlık Örgütü'nün sınıflaması.
24 yaş ve üzerini yetişkin kabul ediyoruz.
18-24 de genç yetişkin.
Peki, 24 yaş ve üzeri.
Şu oku biraz ilerletelim.
25 yaşında bir dişiye
kız mı dersiniz kadın mı?
Yani şu geçiş ne zaman oluyor?
İşte burada, toplumda çok ciddi
bir anlam karmaşası var.
Ama karmaşa kelimede değil,
çok daha derinlerde.
Ben size bunu anlatacağım.
Sorumuza dönelim,
24 yaşında bir dişi
kız mı dersiniz kadın mı?
Bana hemen şunu sorarsınız:
evli mi?
Aslında orada onu sormak
istemiyorsunuz siz.
De ötekini de nasıl soracağız şimdi?
Değil mi?
Evet, merak ettiğimiz şey
maalesef cinsel deneyimi.
Ona göre kadın veya kız diyeceğiz.
Hani erişkin dişiydi?
Niye biz bunu medeni duruma
veya cinsel öyküye dönüştürdük?
Kelimenin korkutuculuğu burada başlıyor.
Ben size kadın kelimesinin
korkutuculuğunu anlatacağım.
Kadın cinsiyet belirten bir kelime sadece,
erkek gibi, kadın, erkek.
Ama biz cinsiyet belirten
bir kelimeyi almışız
cinsel öykü belirten bir
kelimeye çevirmişiz.
Yani, Türk Dil Kurumu erişkin dişi diyor
ama biz "cinsel deneyimi olan"
dişi diyoruz aslında.
Buradan bir konuya geleceğim,
bayan-kadın tartışmaları değil mi?
Bundan bahsetmesek olmaz.
Ama, üzgünüm ama ben burada
erkeklere hak veriyorum.
Şimdi tanımadığı bir dişiye diyelim,
yolda hitap etmesi gerekiyor,
hanımefendi demek aklına
gelmiyor diyelim ki.
Şimdi, bayan-kadın dedik.
Tanımadığı bir dişi yürüyor yolda,
hanımefendi demek de aklına
gelmiyor diyelim.
Kadın dediğinde alacağı tepkiyi
düşünebiliyor musunuz?
Biraz sert bir tepki olabilir, değil mi?
Dolayısıyla, erkekler de bayan
kelimesine sığınıyor aslında.
Kadın derse başına
gelecekleri bilmediğinden.
Peki, kadın derse niye
başına bir şey geliyor?
Çünkü, sorun erkeklerde değil.
Kadının kendisini "kadın" diye
tanımlarkenki çatışmasında.
Neden? Türk Dil Kurumu'ndan tutun da,
demin anlattığım anlama kadar.
Çünkü bu cinsellik belirten
bir ifadeye çevrilmiş.
Ve toplumun kadın kelimesine
yüklediği anlamı,
o da haklı olarak kendisine alıyor.
Aslında (toplum) size
haksızlık da etmeyelim.
Şurada, çok kısa bir dönem
kadın olmanıza izin veriyor.
Ne zaman bu biliyor musunuz?
Evlendikten anne olana kadarki dönem.
Burada, hem kadın kendisine
"evet, ben kadınım" diye tanımlıyor
hem de toplum ona rahatlık kadın diyor.
Hani, sevgili Duygu Asena
"kadının adı yok" diyor ya.
Kadının adı değil, kadının kendi yok!
Kadın yok.
Bir örnek daha vereyim.
45 ya da 50 yaşlarında evlenmemiş
bir hanımefendiyi düşünelim.
Ne diyoruz?
Evde kalmış kız, evde kalmış kız kurusu.
Gene kadın olamadı!
Niye evde kalmış kadın demiyoruz?
Madem evde kalmışı kullanacağız,
hadi kabul ettik.
Gene kadın olamadı.
Peki biraz daha gerilere gidelim.
Küçük çocuğa inelim, kız oğlan
tanımlarına gelelim.
Ne diyor Türk Dil Kurumu kıza?
Dişi çocuk. Peki.
Oğlana bakalım, karşılığı: erkek çocuk.
Tamam.
Şimdi, kız çocuğunun
büyümesinden korkuyoruz ya
kadın olmak, hakaret
gibi kabul ediliyor ya.
Erkekte de tam tersi var.
O da bir an önce büyüsün istiyoruz,
oğlan denilmesin ona istiyoruz.
Neden?
Şu tanımdan dolayı.
Yani, biri bir an önce büyüsün erkek olsun
ama diğeri hep çocuk kalsın, kız kalsın.
Burada asıl amaç cinsellik yaşamasın.
Peki niye bu konuyu seçtim?
Ne demek istiyorum?
Kadın kelimesinin ve onu çağrıştıran
her kelime veya tümcenin
ayıp karşılanmasının, çekinilmesinin,
bu kelimeden kaçınılmasının
tek bir sebebi var.
Kadını cinsel kimliğinden uzak tutmak.
Kadının cinselliğini görmezden
gelmek ya da yok saymak.
Kadının cinsiyetinin ve
hormonlarının ona verdiği
cinsiyet, doğurganlık,
üreme yeteneğini kabul edip
cinselliği ona hak görmemek.
Psikanaliz bunu çok güzel açıklıyor.
Yani bunun bilimsel açıklaması da var.
O, kız kadın anne vardı ya,
kadın sadece ve sadece anne kimliği
ile korkutucu olmaktan çıkıyor.
Anne olana kadarki
-o zaten adı olmayan dönemde-
korkutucu ve tehlikeli.
Hatta biz buna yöresel olarak bir
kelime daha eklemişiz:
namus nesnesi.
Namusun hiçbir dilde karşılığı yok
biliyor musunuz sözlükte?
Erdem, dürüstlük, gerçek namusun var.
Ama bizim kast ettiğimiz
bacak arası namusun
Türkçe dışında hiçbir dilde karşılığı yok.
Kadının cinselliğini yok saymak dedik ya,
bir de bunun fiziksel yapılan hali var.
Vahşice kadının cinselliğini yok etmek.
Evet, kadın sünnetinden bahsedeceğim.
Ben buna çok aşinayım.
Ben Afrika'ya çok sık gidiyorum.
Gönüllü doktor olarak orada
ameliyatlar yapıyorum,
muayeneler yapıyorum.
Şimdi, muayenelerde enteresan bir şey var.
Kadınlara baktığımda
genital anatomi farklı.
Hani biri doğumsal olabilir, anlamadım
görmediğim bir anatomi var.
Nedir bu diye yanımdaki oradaki
yerel görevliye sorduğumda
"hocam onlar sünnetli kadınlar" dedi.
Size ne olduğunu anlatayım,
ne yaptıklarını.
Birleşmiş Milletler buna
"genital sakatlama"diyor,
bu şekilde geçiyor.
Şimdi, 3 tipi var:
ya klitorisi çıkarıyorlar, ya klitorisle
beraber iç dudakları çıkarıyorlar,
ya da tüm genital bölgeyi
çıkarıp dikiyorlar.
Sadece âdet kanı ve idrarın
akışına izin verecek şekilde.
Bu üçüncünün diğer amacı
da ne biliyor musunuz?
Evlendiğinde, eşi bıçakla açıyor orayı ki
bakire olduğundan emin oluyor.
Şimdi, evet bu vahşice
ama çok sık yapılıyor.
Bu tüm konuşmayı da bunun için yapıyorum.
Biz de kelimelerimizle çok da
farklı bir şey yapmıyoruz.
Orada amaç zevk almasın, haz duymasın.
Bir kadının zevk alması
niye bu kadar korkutucu?
Öyle korkutucu ki!
Bir de bunu sağlama alıyorlar.
Bu sünnet edilen çocuklar,
yaklaşık 5 yaşında kız çocukları.
Evet, bu Uganda'dan bir
fotoğraf, yetimhaneden.
Bunun bu arada bir dinle falan ilgisi yok.
Mesela, Somali %85i müslüman
olan bir ülke, çok sıktı.
Kongo Demoktratik Cumhuriyeti'ne
gittiğimde,
orası da yüzde 80-85 hristiyan
ve katolik bir ülke,
orada da çok sıktı.
Bunun dinle bir ilgisi yok.
Ve bu sünnetlerde bu kız çocuklarının çoğu
kan kaybından kaybediliyor.
Bir o kadarı da, bunlar yaşlı
kadınların aynı jileti kullanarak
yaptıkları işlemler, AIDS bulaşıyor.
Zaten çok yaygın.
Ya inanılmaz kötü bir şey.
Tabii psikolojik etkilerini
hiç konuşmuyorum.
Bu hala bitmedi.
Evet, insan hakları ihlali ama
Birleşmiş Milletler'in raporuna göre
önümüzdeki 10 yılda hala
30 milyon kız çocuğu
sünnet tehlikesi ile karşı karşıya.
Bu bir tek doğuda değil, batıda da böyle
yine etnik gruplar arasında
Amerika'da da Avrupa'da da
sünnet hâlâ var.
Peki, biraz da özel olalım değil mi?
Kadınlarımız özeldir, özeldir...
Güzel bir kelimemiz var:
"kadının özel günleri".
Değil mi? Âdet günleri.
Peki, size polikliniğimden bir diyalogla
devam etmek istiyorum.
Steteskobu olan benim, bana
benzeyen bir şey seçtik.
Şimdi, şunu soruyorum:
en son ne zaman âdet gördünüz?
Bu benim için çok önemli.
Hani fonksiyonel bir sıkıntı var mı diye.
Evet, aldığım cevap:
"dün temizlendim".
"Kirli miydiniz?"
"Evet, 5 gün kirli kalıyorum, ama
zamanında kirlenirim hep, hiç aksamaz".
Evet, gülüyorsunuz ama benim
çok sık yaşadığım bir şey öykü alırken.
Sizce burada kast edilen
hijyenik bir kirlenme mi?
Maalesef değil.
Çünkü âdet gördüğünde,
kadın o ay gebe kalmayacak demek.
Gebe kalmayacak, hani anne olamayacak ya
bu da bunun bir yansıması.
O zaman kirli.
Peki, bu kirlenme dediğiniz şeyin
dünyanın en temiz şeyi olduğunu
biliyor musunuz?
Biz niye âdet görürüz,
ya da niye "kirleniriz"?
Yeni bir yaşam başlayacak.
O yüzden vücut onu öyle bir sisteme
alıyor ki, o kadar titizlikle.
Yepyeni olsun diye
her ay yenisini yapıyor.
Âdet dediğimiz şey, her ay,
rahmin bir iç tabakası var
bebeğin yerleştiği yer,
orası bebek gelecek diye
hazırlanır, kalınlaşır,
damarlanması artar, bir yuva oluşturulur,
âdet görülmesse o yuva dökülür.
Biz buna âdet kanaması diyoruz.
Ama "kirlenme" de diyoruz.
Peki, tıbbi olarak size bunu gösterip
gebe kalmaya geçeceğim.
Bir animasyon üzerinden göstereceğim.
Şimdi, bu bizim alt karın bölgemiz,
genital organlarımız.
Kabaca, şu armut gibi
gördüğünüz şey rahim,
yandakiler yumurtalıklar ve tüpler.
Şimdi her ay hormonların etkisiyle,
şu yumurtalıklarımızdan
birinde yumurta oluşmaya başlıyor.
Bunlar doğuştan beri bekliyor orada.
Bir tanesi büyüyor ve atılıyor.
Biz buna yumurtlama diyoruz.
Bu her ay oluyor, düzenli bir şekilde.
Bu yumurtlama olurken, oradan
salınan hormonların etkisiyle
-bahsettiğim rahmin iç tabakası burası-
kalınlaşıyor.
Niye kalınlaşıyordu? Bebek gelirse diye.
Peki, cinsel ilişki oldu. Milyonlarca
spermden bir tanesi döllemeyi başardı.
Bebek oluştu, o hazır olmuş
yuvaya geliyor, yerleşiyor.
Tebrikler, gebesiniz!
Doğuracaksınız, anne olacaksınız,
Cennet ayaklarınızın altında.
Değil mi?
Peki, diyelim ki gebelik oluşmadı.
Bakın o zaman da, yumurta döllenmedi ya,
ya da tutunamıyor döllendi,
o oluşmuş iç tabaka dökülüyor.
İşte biz buna âdet kanaması diyoruz.
Yani, görüyor musunuz ne kadar
titizlikle hazırlanmış bir şey,
her ay yenisi yapılıyor ve
biz buna "kirlenmek" diyoruz.
Daha da önemlisi var,
bir kız çocuğunun ilk âdet
gördüğünü düşünün.
Âdet görmek ve doğurganlık kadındaki
en kompleks mekanizma.
Hipofiz bezinden başlıyor, bir sürü
hormonların etkisi var.
Bu kız çocuğunda, hepsi
çok sağlam bir şekilde çalışıyor,
sağlıklı doğurgan demek.
E niye ayıplıyoruz?
Niye kız çocuğu ben âdet gördüm
diye çıkamıyor?
Niye bunu saklıyor?
Anne olacak işte!
Biraz sinirlendim, düzeleyim.
Peki...
Size sinirlenmedim, eminim burada
hiç öyle düşünen yok.
Peki, bir şey daha anlatacağım şimdi.
Yine bunlar tıbbi kısımlar.
Anne karnında cinsiyet nasıl oluşuyor?
Değil mi?
Leylekler niye bazen kız,
bazen erkek getiriyor?
Şimdi, o döllenme var ya,
o anda hangi şampiyon sperm
oraya ulaşıp döllemeyi başardıysa,
o taşıdığı kromozom Y ise erkek bebek
oluyor, X ise kız bebek oluyor.
Bu oran %50.
Peki, diyelim ki erkek, Y kromozomu
taşıyor, erkek çocuk doğacak.
Öyle hemen olmuyor birleşmeyle.
Diyor ki o Y kromozomundaki bir bölge:
iki bebeğin de 1,5 aylık
olana kadar anne karnında,
ortak bir yumurtalığı var.
O bölge diyor ki, bu çocuk
erkek olacak diyor
sen diyor onu testis yap diyor,
testise dönüş diyor.
Ve testis oluşuyor.
Sonra da başka bir madde diyor ki:
testosteron salgıla, erkek bebek olacak.
Bu hormonun etkisiyle de erkeğin
iç üreme organları oluşuyor.
Sonra yine enzimsel başka bir basamakla da
erkeğin dış organları oluşuyor.
Erkek çocuk doğuyor, sıkıntı yok.
Peki, kız bebeğe gelelim.
Kız bebek ne demek? X taşıyordu Y yok,
ya bu bölge yok.
Hiçbir hormon vermeseniz de
-ki anne karnında almıyor-
ya östrojen uyarısı anne karnında
yok kız bebekte,
testosteron olmadığı için direk sağlıklı
bir kız bebek doğuyor.
Ya, tüm bu sistemler o testis yerine
yumurtalığa dönüyor,
yumurtalıktan sonra rahim ve
iç genital organlar oluşuyor.
Sonra da dış üreme organları oluşuyor,
kız bebek oluyor.
Ya burada söylemek istediğim
hiçbir şey vermeseniz de
doğa kız yapmaya meyilli.
Evet, kadın cinsiyeti yapıyor.
Ya, doğa bunu yapıyor ve erkeğin
o uzun bir yolu vardı ya
hani hormonlar oluşuyordu,
iç üreme vesaire,
orada herhangi bir
doğumsal kusur olduğunda
hop dişiye dönüyor gene.
Mesela şöyle düşünün,
kromozomu Y, testisi var,
testosteron üretiyor,
işte prostat vesaire
iç üreme organları oluşmuş,
tam orada bir doğumsal kusur var.
Dış üreme organları oluşamıyor.
Ama oluşamıyor değil,
ne oluyor biliyor musunuz?
Kız organları oluşuyor.
Yani, takıldığı yerde doğa onu
hemen dişiye çeviriyor.
Siz orada ne diyorsunuz?
"Aaa kızım oldu" diyorsunuz.
Bu kız geliyor, ergenlik döneminde
âdet görmüyor,
niye âdet görmüyor diye
bize getiriyorsunuz.
Biz bakıyoruz diyoruz ki:
"e bu kız değil ki".
Nasıl değil? Kromozomlarına bakıyoruz başka bir şey,
içeride rahim, yumurtalık yok
hatta testis var, karnında.
İşte bunlar da cinsiyet bozuklukları.
Neyse bu çok karmaşık bir konu...
Demek istediğim şu,
doğa kadın yapmaya çalışıyor.
Evet, erkek tali bir cinsiyet
mi acaba? Bu esprisi tabii...
Bir de şu gözle bakarsanız tam tersi,
"erkek olmak ciddi iş".
Değil mi?
Evet, yani, sen kalk o kadar
milyon spermin içinden ulaş,
bir taneyi dölle, şampiyon ol,
sonra bütün bu mekanizmaları geç,
hormonların doğru çalışsın,
bütün enzimlerin doğru çalışsın,
son basamağa kadar, erkek oluyorsun ya.
Gerçekten zor iş.
Şaka olsun diye söylemiyorum.
Bakın iki farklı bakış açısı.
Tali cinsiyetten özel cinsiyete.
Peki, o zaman bir de yine
Türk Dil Kurumu'na dönelim.
Dişi ile erkeğin tanımına bakalım.
Yumurta oluşturan veya
yavru doğuran birey.
Peki.
Yetmiyor, şuh, işveli, çekici olacak
bir de ki dişi olabilsin.
Değil mi?
Bu kadar size kadın anlatıyorum
diye böyle giyindim.
Sırf bu sebeple.
Evet, yetmedi yani.
Erkeğe bakalım,
yetişkin adam, bay, peki.
Sperm oluşturan organizma,
tamam bunu anlattık zaten.
Yetmedi, sözüne güvenilir,
mert olacak bir de.
Yani şimdi erkek oldu
yetmiyor, adam olacak.
O da yetmiyor, adam gibi adam olacak yahu!
Peki, yani farkındaysanız
dengeli anlatıyorum,
öyle erkeklere sıkıntılı bir şey
anlatacağımı düşünmeyin.
Dönelim kadın tanımına, çok güldük.
Bakın, analık veya ev yönetimi bakımından
gereken erdemleri ve becerileri olan.
Şimdi, sağlıklı yüz çiftten her şeyi
yolunda olan 15 tanesinde gebelik oluşmaz.
Biz bunları araştırmaya başlarız.
Siz bu 15 kadını erdemsiz yaptınız,
becereksiz yaptınız,
bir de kadın olmaktan bile attınız.
Bunların öyle hikâyeleri var ki,
her ay gebe miyim diye
âdet gördüklerinde,
bir de onlara kirli diyorsunuz.
Oturur ağlarsınız.
Evet, şimdi size komik bir şey
daha göstereceğim.
Benim bir meslek ilanım.
Bayan kadın doğum uzmanı.
Hani aynıydı bu ikisi madem.
Niye ikisi de bayan değil,
biri bayan biri kadın?
Benim aklıma birkaç şey geliyor.
Bir, doktorun cinsel deneyimini
bilmiyoruz ya,
nasıl kadın diyeceğiz şimdi,
bayan diyelim ona.
Doktor ya, biraz daha saygıyı hak ediyor,
ona bayan diyelim.
Öteki zaten kadın doğumcuya gidiyor,
ilişkisi var demek ki bırak o kadın kalsın.
Tabii bir de bunun daha
bir kötü versiyonu var,
"bayandan az kullanılmış".
Evet, bu bütün dünyada böyle,
bizde değil merak etmeyin.
Sadece onlar kelimeleri bu
kadar rahat kullanamıyorlar.
Onlarda da "kız gibi yapmak",
"kız gibi koşmak" vesaire var.
Orada sorun farklı yapmak değil,
eksik veya yetersiz yapmak.
Ben bunu çok yaşıyorum.
Nerede yaşıyorum?
Ben bir cerrahım, ameliyatlar yapıyorum.
Evet, benim asistanlık
eğitimim şöyle geçti,
vakada bir hata yaptığımızda,
ameliyatta yanlış bir şey yaptığınızda
ameliyathaneden atılırken,
şu sözler eşliğinde atılırdık:
"kız gibi ameliyat yapma!".
Yalnız size bir şey söyleyeyim,
"kız gibi" çok güzel ameliyat yapılıyor.
Hele bir de "kadın" gibi yaparsanız...
Evet, biz yine çok şanslıyız. Neden?
Bütün dünyada birçok ülkeden önce
kadına değer veren, kadına
seçme-seçilme hakkını veren
bir liderimiz var bizim.
Bu topraklardan çıkmış.
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk'ümüz var!
Ben, bu sahnede, bu coğrafyada
bir kadın olarak
kadını size anlatabiliyorsam,
O'nun sayesinde.
Ben O'na teşekküre çok sık gidiyorum,
her sene Dolmabahçe Sarayı'na.
Tek başıma da gitmiyorum.
Bunlar benim doğumunu
yaptırttığım çocuklar.
Çete kurdum.
Önce annelerinin karnında geliyorlar,
ertesi sene de işte böyle beşikte arabada
sonra da yürüyerek geliyorlar.
Evet, Atatürk'e böyle teşekküre gidiyoruz,
onlara Atatürk'ü ben
anlatıyorum özellikle.
Evet, ben Atatürk'e teşekküre giderken
her sene gidiyorum, her ameliyatımda da
bonemde gördüğünüz gibi O'na
teşekkürlerimi sunuyorum.
Ama müsaadenizle bir de
burada sunmak istiyorum.
Canım Ata'm, canım Atatürk'üm!
Senin sayende, senin kurduğun Cumhuriyet,
senin ilke ve inkılapların, senin vizyonun
ve senin önderliğinde
özgür, çağdaş, laik,
en hakiki mürşiti ilim olan
bir Türk kadını ve bir Türk hekimi olarak,
ait olduğum coğrafyada bu günlerime
tek başıma gelebildim.
Senin sayende.
Sana minnettarım ve ölene kadar izindeyim.